esta historia podría comenzar en
cualquier momento de nuestras vidas
ese momento en el cual sientes que no
encajas en ningún lugar estás solo
ponen música para acompañar pero qué
música pusiste
[Música]
y es como si todo te hiciera sentir peor
porque cuando hablamos de comunicación
emocional
todos somos diferentes sin embargo en
principio todos hemos aprendido algo por
imitación y si alguna vez se han
preguntado qué es lo que hace el
director de orquesta con sus manos pues
dar el ejemplo para orquestar todas esas
diferencias a través de la técnica neuro
directorial
o el arte de liderar sin hablar
qué son las cinco dimensiones con las
que el director de orquesta transforma
una idea cualquiera en una experiencia
maravillosa
la dimensión mecánica
la dinámica
la expresiva
la energética
y la espiritual
y yo comprendí de que esa técnica podía
aplicarse a cualquier experiencia de
nuestra vida
mi historia comienza seis años atrás
cuando un amigo toca mi puerta y me dice
roger la orquesta de la universidad se
ha quedado sin director y queremos que
tú nos dirías
hasta ese momento yo nunca había tocado
en honor que está mucho menos dirigirla
así que st
porque cuando fue la última vez que
hiciste algo por primera vez
cuando es el ensayo le pregunté ahora en
la tarde
así que rápidamente tome la batuta y la
magia de la dirección ocurrió en ese
momento supe exactamente qué era lo que
quería hacer dirigir porque éstas
recorrí el país buscando formación
para ser director de orquesta tienes que
tener un pregrado musical cinco años
doce si quieres ser profesional y yo
pensaba haber no nos estamos entendiendo
yo ya tengo una orquesta y necesito a
alguien que me enseñe a dirigirlas para
algo que estoy haciendo hoy día no para
algo que quisiera hacer en cinco años
más y fue ahí cuando escuché la verdad
roger
entonces aquí no hay formación para ti
pero decidido a no rendirme comencé a
buscar alternativas no convencionales en
internet
y fue así como conocí al maestro
francisco navarro lara y su fantástica
escuela de dirección de orquesta en
huelva españa que justo en ese momento
había organizado brabo maestro el primer
reality show para directores de orquesta
del mundo
se imagina en un reality show de
directores de orquesta
si ya el director de orquesta tiene esa
figura seria ahora imagínense 40
encerrados en un teatro
ese tiene que ser el reality show más
perno de la historia original
así que postulen
o yo
pero para clasificar tenía que enviar un
vídeo dirigiendo una sinfónica y yo de
dónde iba a sacar una sinfónica
aún recuerdo el rostro de mi madre
cuando ese día llegue a casa y me dice
roger
en qué momento se te ocurrió la idea
y yo en mi nerviosismo le respondí mamá
da gracias que no se me ocurrió ser
astronauta porque hay quiero ver de
dónde sacamos un cohete
y fueron mis amigos de la academia de
artes de las católicas quienes me
ayudaron a continuar y no sin dificultad
logré clasificar
y allá en españa el maestro nos esperaba
con una gran invitación
quien quiere subirse al escenario
pero ahora no para dirigir una orquesta
sino para que todos nosotros lo
dirigimos a él
vengo de jaio españolizado total por la
pura emoción
venga roger aquí habéis venido cuál es
el sueño que queréis cumplir
y yo respondí yo quiero ser el mejor
coach musical del mundo y ayudarles a
ustedes a convertirse en los mejores
directores de orquesta del siglo 21
y la pregunta que vino después fue la
que cambió mi vida para siempre
y por qué no lo eres
y yo estaba expuesto ahí antes los que
seguramente eran los mejores directores
de orquestas del siglo 21
y les conté mi dolor
ese fue para mí el tercer plano
dimensional el de la expresión
roger ellos solo te conocen por lo que
tú les has contado eso es realmente lo
que quieres decir en nuevo por supuesto
que no
entonces diles que ese rollo termina
aquí
hasta ese momento yo solo me había
dejado llevar por las oportunidades que
la vida me daba pero acaso no se trata
de todo lo contrario de cuanto de ti
tiene la vida que estás viviendo y día
y ahí comencé a ver música en todas
partes y comprendí que mi vida había
nacido porque estaba para transmitirles
los sentimientos de los músicos la
disciplina de las orquestas y el
liderazgo de sus director a las
experiencias de la vida cotidiana fue
así que nació symphony el primer centro
de innovación musical de chile
y desde ahí convertía la música en mi
vehículo para cumplir mis sueños
pude darle gracias a dios tocando el
papá francisco en su visita chile
pueden demostrar de que el amor existe
con la propuesta de matrimonio más
romántica de la historia
y junto a la mejor orquesta del mundo
puede consagrar mi vida como embajadora
musical por la paz mundial
qué distinto es cuando tienes un paraje
un amigo me dijo justo antes de subir
aquí
después de ese viaje ni tú sabes dónde
vas a llegar y verme aquí estoy en una
te de c's así que quisiera hacer un
experimento con todos ustedes y si me
permiten también contarles mi dolor
todo lo que yo he hecho en la vida lo he
hecho con muchísimo miedo
tengo pánico escénico
y ser director de orquesta ha sido
bastante conveniente
porque le das la espalda al público
pero por eso es que en esta ocasión yo
quiero que ustedes me puedan acompañar
ya sea cantando con las palmas en el
primer concierto para público y orquesta
de una text
y desafiarme a mí a dirigir al revés ya
no mirando la orquesta sino tanto en la
cara a usted
[Música]
[Aplausos]
i
[Música]
y es así como llegas a momentos mágicos
como este
cuando decides orquestar tu vida
como una obra maestra
[Aplausos]